あああああ、
髪の毛が赤い
髪の毛、赤いんですけど
マニックパニックで染めたんで多分、あと一週間もすれば普通の茶髪に戻ると思います。
もうしばらくお待ちください
はい！という訳で今日は
何と
あのこの動画ご存じでしょうか？
どうぞ！
ちょ、俺も見てみよ
どんなんだっけな
フッ
若い！髪の毛が短い！
これそうなんですあの～、
電球でテニスをするんですけど
トミックさんを起こさないように電球でテニスをするっていう
動画を昔、やりました！
トミックさんを起こさないようにする動画です
アハハ
電球割れ音
あはっはは！
あははは！
あはははは
よだれでちゃった！
はい！という動画があるんですけども
何か、自分の動画見て笑うの恥ずかしいな
昔、こういう電球でテニスしてみたっていう動画あったんですけど
今回なんと！
なんとですね！
この、『電球でテニスしてみた』がゲームになりました！
マジか
ゲームなったらしいですよ！
何か電球でテニスしてみたって言うゲームなんで
おそらく、ゲームではトミックさんを起こさないようにするゲームだと思います！
僕もまだ実際にプレイしとことないんで実際にプレイしてみましょう
ちなみにさっき、まさきのやらせてみたら
こういう反応でした！どうぞ！
クッ、アハハハハ
何？
アハハハハ！
そんなに？そんなに？
ちょっと難しい
ああ～！そういう事もあるの？
何か面白いんだけど
新記録でたよ
えっ？
何か、僕ふざけてやってただけ何でちょっと心配なんですけども
実際にやってみましょう！
では行こう！
はい！という訳で実際にやって行きましょう！
こういう感じでもう普通にあのダウンロードできます
電球でテニスしてみた
はぁだと
もうちょっと絵に悪意が
アアッウン
はじめしゃちょーとテニスして高得点だそう
トミックが起きたらゲームオーバー
起こさないようにラリーを続けよう！
アハハッ
遊び方がちゃんと書いてありますね
タイミングを合わせて画面をタップして電球とかを打ち返そう
なるほど、実際にやってみましょう！
なるほど、なるほど
トミックさんの家がこう正確に作られてますね
素晴らしいです
電球とかをタイミングよくタップしよう
ピンクのサークルが合図だよと
起きそうになったら隠れるボタンを長押ししてうまく隠れよう！
分かりました！一回やってみよう！
どうすればいいの？これ
どうすればいいの？
あっ
なんか、これで打ち返すのか！
わっ
なるほど、なるほど
オッケ、オッケオッケ！
ほう！
ヤバイ！
フッフフ
オッケ！
アレイッ！
フフフッ俺こんなに内股か？！
ヤバイ！
あー！起きちゃった！
ハハハッハ
なるほどね
55,800点
このちょっとイラストがもう！
トミックさんも顎がすごい割れてますね！
やった、やったな！図鑑解放条件クリアだ！おめでとう！
一人、No１が解放されました！
おお！
おお！スゲー！ Tシャツ１００はじめんだぁ！！
なるほど、なるほどこういう感じで
どんどん図鑑がこう増えてく訳ですね
ちょ、一回本気でやってみます！
僕ぐらいだと多分ハイスコアが出せるはずなんで
ヤバイ！
あー！バレた！！
畜生、悔しいな！
お！やった！もうNo２出た！
これ、233,300点って結構すごくないですか？
おっ
アハハハ
ハハハッ
汚なっ！
図鑑のNo２ちょっと汚いですね
これを実際皆さんやって見てください！
という訳で僕のハイスコア、233,300点でございます！
くそっもうちょい、いけると思うんだけどな
軽く気楽に出来るゲームなのでよかったら是非ね
トミックさんを起こさないように
頑張ってみてください
動画の説明欄からダウンロード出来ると思います！
また、トミックさん起こさずに何かやって見ます！
じゃあな！